Oh,
how many of you saw the New York Times yesterday morning?
What'd you say?
Yes.
So the front and center,
uh,
a story
and the times is good.
Get My,
uh,
my pointer.
So,
uh,
this is a girl.
So in Afghanistan,
one of the ways of suppressing women is to keep them from getting any education.
And so with these girls go to school because you'll learn a lot about that in
the course of why they want to go to school wide.
Their parents want them to go to school.
So they go to school and three guys came up on a motorcycle.
Um,
they don't have a motorcycle motor scooter and they just asked the girls how
you're going to school.
They're walking to school in the morning.
And the girl said,
yes,
threw acid in their faces.
And this story is about that kind of thing happening right now in Afghanistan.
Uh,
when this happened,
the girl,
everybody was of course very scared,
but the parents,
one set of parents that were quoted here said,
you must go to school.
Even if you're killed,
they're going to school is more important than their lives in these communities.
And you'll understand a lot later why.
Okay.
Now one other notable thing happened,
so that's quite amazing.
I talk about it on Tuesday and Wednesday morning up comes a the New York Times
story.
This happens every year.
I think there's a spy in the class.
So,
uh,
the next thing is a student said,
oh,
she loved the lecture,
but what did she love about it?
She loved the Dung Beetles.
And so she sent me her own personal picture of Dung Beetles
and uh,
she lacks a little bit poetic about them.
Um,
I have to let you know that Dung beetles are among my favorite animals.
The best part is watching the males agonize over rolling the ball over to the
whole while the female rides relaxed,
just planting her eggs inside it.
The ultimate feminism,
if you ask me now,
the student wants to remain anonymous so that you all don't think that she's a
little kinky.
Maybe
that's nothing wrong with that.
This is,
this is where very liberal minded here in this class.
Now,
how many of you were not here last time?
Oh,
a few of you.
So I should give a very short summary of what went on last time.
Uh,
I was describing the basic biology of how the social organization of the species
is organized around their sex and reproductive function.
And for virtually all species of higher than,
than single cell organisms,
the female puts a lot of,
uh,
makes big eggs,
a lot of investment.
She doesn't make that many eggs.
They're rare and expensive.
The male sperm is very tiny.
He can make a huge amount of them.
And so they are plentiful and very cheap.
Um,
males then given the excess of sperm that males can inseminate many females,
the males then must compete for the females.
And they have two mechanisms,
either sperm competition where there's the sexual system is polygamous,
uh,
promiscuous.
And many males will mate with the same female,
the same female will mate with many males,
and then the sperms themselves will compete by a whole variety of mechanisms to
see which sperm will fertilize the egg.
Uh,
the other US mail strategy is to physically fight with other males to gain
control of the female or to compete in some other way,
like displaying your,
the peacock with this enormous tail displaying.
I've got a more beautiful tail than you do.
Or we talked about,
uh,
birds dancing.
The males dance for a long time and display their,
their mental ability to dance coordinated Lee and their beauty and stamina to
the females.
Then the females choose.
The females also have two strategies.
I mean,
obviously this is a great simplification.
The females also have two strategies.
One is to get resources from the mail as in the Dung Beetle.
There's the,
the,
the Dung balls are full of nitrogen,
which is a very rare,
uh,
and uh,
so they,
they feed this to the female and female then can produce more eggs in it,
which is evolutionary leap.
Very good for both the male and the female or the female wants,
uh,
to choose the male with the best genes.
And so in some way the males have to display what are the best jeans in best
just means those that are successful reproductively sometimes bigger is better,
sometimes smaller is better.
Sometimes fast it's better.
Sometimes slow is better.
Better does not mean anything.
And fitness,
the word fitness,
which you've heard does not mean anything other than leads,
more offspring.
It can be any kind of phenotype.
You can imagine any kind of body type and he kind of ability or the opposite in
some ecological situations being fat as good.
And other times being skinny,
uh,
it's good.
So,
uh,
the females either watch the males display,
watch the peacock's tail or observe the end of fighting between the males.
That one male becomes dominant,
then the female is happy to copulate with that male.
When males fight,
no,
the males tend to get large cause that helps them in the fight.
Evolution makes them larger and they'd get larger than the females.
And once they're larger than the females,
they can start coercing the females.
And that's really the origin of the biological origin of a lot of male female
violence that males can either to gain access to female,
they can either fight with other males,
which can be very difficult and you're liable to get damaged or killed or just
coerce a female who's smaller and less strong.
And so you get mail coercion of females
and in primates,
the last sort of in primates and the great apes,
we are all great apes in particular.
This tendency toward male violence onto females is carried to,
uh,
is his most prominent.
And the reason is we invest enormously in our young,
we spend very long time with the young taking care of them.
And therefore the females who do most of the investment can't have very many
young,
they can't have them very rapidly.
And in the great apes,
aside from humans,
which we'll talk about next time,
as an exception,
it takes five to 10 years.
The females don't have a second.
They have a,
a child,
a baby,
then they wait five to 10 years before having a baby again.
So eggs are very difficult to come by.
In a,
in a group of chimps,
maybe one egg a year is available for fertilization and the males compete like
crazy by every possible mechanism,
including a lot of violence to get access to that single,
uh,
egg.
Uh,
okay.
So one anecdote about the relationship of sociality in sexuality has to do with,
uh,
orangutans who are the most distantly related of the great apes from us.
They are just,
they're very clever,
like all the great apes and they use all kinds of ways of being,
uh,
attractive to a male and vice versa.
And one of the ways they use like reduce intellectual brilliance.
I think Yale students are involved,
especially to use intellectual brilliance to
be attracted.
My college girlfriend,
I feel guessing love with her because she could do the Latin and I couldn't,
I was hopeless.
She was just stunned at how well,
how good,
how well she could,
she did it.
Anyway.
Um,
in,
uh,
1978,
a graduate student from Stanford,
uh,
went to the orangutan research station,
Borneo and his job was language.
They are,
you know,
lots of people want to show how close or how different great apes are from
humans.
So language is a special human ability,
but the great apes have a certain degree of it.
And he wanted to find out how much.
So he taught an adult female named Rennie sign language.
And uh,
the guy's name was Gary Shapiro.
Renny was his mate in turns out she was a brilliant student.
She really should have been at Yale,
but she was stuck in Borneo and didn't have the money to come here.
Um,
and she,
Gary just could not believe how fast Reney learned the language.
And so he was just glowing and he loved Rennie and his research project,
he was going to get famous.
You know,
he's probably being able to teach more language than anyone else has ever taught
to,
to an ape.
But Rennie took all this attention quite personally.
She thought there was something going on,
but between the two of them,
it wasn't all intellectual,
but she waited for Gary and nothing happened.
So one day she took the,
uh,
the,
the dominant role as I've heard Yale girls sometimes do,
and she took Gary by the hand and did the obvious things,
uh,
to try to seduce him.
And so there's Gary,
what is he going to do?
Well,
he wasn't very up for this,
uh,
like many Yale guys that I've heard of.
And so Gary just pushed her away,
not thinking an awful lot about it,
but being a scientist,
he hadn't read his literature and he does not know that there is no law,
no wrath,
like the wrath of a woman scorned.
So thereafter,
she lost all interest in signing,
would not cooperate in the lessons,
ruined his phd thesis project.
So let that be a warning guy.
Okay.
So we've,
we talked,
uh,
about,
um,
uh,
we talked last time about Aurangzeb of the great apes,
those five species,
including us.
We talked about the,
uh,
the,
the rape that orangs do.
Uh,
we talked about the infanticide that gorillas do and now we come to chimpanzees
who have yet another system.
Uh,
again,
always coping with this idea of the rarity of female eggs.
Unlike the orangutan in the gorilla at the males are not solitary.
The standard,
the most common.
There is no standard now millions of species.
And they do millions of different things.
Most Standard Mammal thing is for the males in some way to fight with each other
and they push other males away.
And uh,
one male gets one or several females.
There are,
there are exceptions to this,
but that's the most common sort of way chimp and,
uh,
chimpanzees don't do this.
Uh,
they live in a group of males and in fact the males that are born into a,
into a group stay with the group.
So this is a male group that has been staying together for as far back as,
as one can tell.
Male Spacely never transfer groups.
They never leave a group.
Uh,
so these are basically a,
a long line one,
one family set of males,
uh,
within that community.
Uh,
let's see,
I think I have some slides.
Ah,
that's,
that's a picture of the Orang that fell in love with the Grad student.
Now we'll come to Jane Goodall in a,
in a minute.
Um,
given that there are males together,
what they do then is compete for dominance.
And a lot of that is physical fighting and their dominance position gives them
access to food and to females.
So when a chimp wants to move up in the dominance hierarchy,
uh,
may go through a long period where they're sort of jockeying and various ways,
and I'll describe some of the jockeying going on.
Uh,
largely big displays,
beating the chest,
uh,
if there's anything around shaking branches,
stomping on the ground,
uh,
hollering,
but they don't fight.
But eventually,
if in fact a reversal of dominance position is going to take place,
a real fight almost always does occur.
Not always successfully.
Jane Goodall describes one of these Sherry and they give names to each of the
chimps.
Sherry,
a younger male,
was moving up in the hierarchy and aggressive young male,
you know,
some of those,
he had beat out some of the lower ranking young males,
but the next one on his list was named Satan.
You can tell from the name,
this was not a wise move.
Satan was not the Alpha male,
but was higher than Sherry.
They had a huge fight when it was over.
Sherry was bleeding from bad wounds on his shoulder,
both hands his back,
his head,
and one leg.
Sherri escaped and ran away screaming loudly.
This was apparently such a bad,
uh,
experience that Sherry never again attempted to dominate any other male.
He had been whipped and he learned whatever his instincts may or may not have
been about aggression.
He learned that's not his game.
He never tried this again.
So they do a lot of threats and displays as a prior to these fights.
But if there's going to be a real reversal,
uh,
there's usually a fight and the fights can get very severe in the wild.
The loser just runs away and they don't carry the fight to the death.
And by the end of the lecture,
you should understand why they don't want to kill each other.
But in a zoo,
when the,
when the chimps are in captivity,
uh,
the males can escape.
And then that proximity leads to a prolongation of the violence and sometimes,
uh,
to death.
Um,
France Deval who you'll do some reading from him.
He describes one fight where the loser had an ear gone,
uh,
the other ear torn his hands and feet badly,
mauled with several bones exposed and some fingers and toes missing a Gash,
stretched one shoulder to the opposite hip.
And a two toes were missing.
And this guy was really beat up.
And so they took him to a human type hospital and try to fix them up.
Didn't work.
He died.
So in,
within a group,
uh,
the fights basically never end in death.
In captivity,
they do end to end in death.
That's within group fighting.
So this finding your place in the dominance hierarchy is a very serious
business.
Uh,
you can either win and go up or you can lose and stay either.
Dot,
you know,
and get very badly physically damaged or Steve or be relegated to a low place.
Humans called dominance,
hierarchy status.
And when you,
when I,
when I used dominance,
think status,
we don't always use the word here,
but I think one of the things if you want to compare chimps and humans,
think of the various things that humans do,
uh,
for status.
So chimps live in groups of about 40 individuals with a dozen or so adult males,
approximately the same number of females.
And as with orangutans that I described to you,
the female,
they have a big range,
15 square kilometers,
40 square kilometers,
something like that.
And they wonder about this.
The females when they have a young are usually fairly isolated.
Not,
not necessarily,
not all the time,
but mostly they're by themselves with their young,
it's a very stable group that always stays together.
Uh,
as,
as I told you last time,
the mother is never out of either touch or,
or,
or sight or hearing of their young for five or more,
five to 10 years.
Uh,
the males on the other hand wander round also,
but they bond together.
They traveled together and they are very often in parties and they go around
certain searching for food and patrolling the borders of the territory.
They also of course visit the females,
go around see which females,
what the sexual status of females is.
And I showed you a slide last time of a male smelling of female sexual
secretions to figure out what status she's in.
Ah,
this looks like something that I have already talked about here tonight.
There's this repeating.
Uh,
all right,
let's see.
So,
um,
yeah,
I don't remember what I,
whether I did this.
Um,
the females are usually quite promiscuous with their sex partners in the
community fall followed by Jane Goodall in each estrous cycle.
Each female had at least set at least one bout of intercourse with every male in
the group.
And I did.
Then I,
I did do this yesterday.
I forgot this,
I dunno how this happens.
Um,
the mail,
how do the males,
uh,
do their,
operate in their dominance hierarchy?
Um,
it's not all violence.
Uh,
one aspect is violence,
but they also make friends with other males.
Single males cannot be successful.
It's a very,
very social situation.
These animals are very clever.
They know each other individually.
They know each other,
propensities,
which ones are dominant,
which ones are not,
which ones are smart,
which ones they can fool,
which ones they can't fool and so on.
So they do a lot of social manipulation,
uh,
to try to get allies in their dominance fights.
Um,
these friendly relations,
you mostly see it as a grooming thing.
Males and females spent a lot of time with each other.
Grooming and what is grooming?
Uh,
uh,
chimps like all kinds of other animals that are infested with parasites,
which can carry diseases and be very dangerous so they have to get rid of them.
So one chimp will sit there and the other chimp will combine and spread the for
very carefully.
And then if there's an insect,
it's good for the person from whom they take the insect.
Cause that insect is no longer can parasitize them and it's good for them.
They get a little bit of protein.
They spent hours and hours doing this,
males to males,
males and females with each other.
And females to females.
Everybody does it with everyone else.
And one of the things that the observers do is count how much time each
individual spends grooming the other.
The,
the person who's the person in the chimp who's being groomed has this wonderful
expression on their face.
They're clearly enjoying this.
It's like a nice massage.
Um,
so,
um,
the purpose of this friendliness or one of the purposes is to help the males
when they engage in dominance fights.
So Jane Goodall describes one of these Goliath,
one of the,
one of the males that we'll talk about later.
So he,
late one evening,
he arrives in camp all by himself and he seems a little on edge every so often
he stands upright and stares back at the direction and from which he had come,
he seems nervous and startles that ev every sound,
six minutes later,
three adult males appear on one of the trails.
And one is the high ranking.
Whew.
They pause,
they see him,
they,
they pause the hair on end.
Then abruptly they charged down toward Goliath.
But he in the time that they were sort of waiting,
he then has disappeared quietly into the forest.
And the next five minutes,
these three big guys thrash around the anniversary,
they're looking for him,
but he has successfully escaped.
He's afraid,
obviously one guy,
one against three,
he's afraid.
The next morning,
Hugh,
uh,
returns to camp with,
with two companions.
Uh,
a few minutes later,
Goliath charge Goliath,
the one that had run away before,
uh,
charges down dragging a huge branch.
That's one of their display,
the kinds of things.
And then he runs straight as he would attack some guy that ran away last time,
one against three is still one against three,
but now he's,
he's the attacker.
A very strange and it's not until the battle is already in progress where,
uh,
where they're grappling and hitting each other that it become obvious why he has
done that.
Because suddenly,
uh,
there's,
there's uh,
the dominant male,
one of the very,
not the Alpha,
one of the strong dominoes is a very big one called David Gray beard.
And while this fight has just begun,
David Greybeard appears me undergrowth and he gives a beat display and Ooh,
it gives a cup some pantsuits and uh,
he's clearly on a gala,
a huge side.
So you and had been obviously been with you just before you came in.
So now he had an ally and then the outcome of the fight,
uh,
was,
was very different.
Suddenly,
Goliath leaps right onto whew.
Uh,
grabbing his hair and shoulder pounding on his back with both feet and he gives
up and he managed to pull away and runs off screaming and defeated.
So the guy that was,
I think I got the names right,
the guy who was scared last night when he has an ally is now the winner.
And the females are almost as good as males in these dominance coalitions
against each other.
So their,
their behavior to arrange these coalitions is extremely complex and manipulative
as,
as I've said,
and they spend huge amounts of their time trying to organize these coalitions.
And then as soon as there's,
so several males will,
will be the,
in a coalition,
one of them will get to be alpha almost immediately.
They become alpha,
the other to go out and form other coalitions to try to displace him.
And we have some of our faculty members like that.
And last night I was reading a book about a renaissance,
uh,
intrigue.
And it was amazing to have,
uh,
some of the big Duke's,
like the meadow cheese and the [inaudible].
And then you have some of these smaller guys and then you have the pope who's
got his own army and there's this constantly floating crap game of who's going
to be allies with who.
And as soon as someone gets some one of these pencils,
principalities gets to be dominant,
the coalition rearranges and everyone else,
it goes against him.
So,
and you can read the history of Europe in the 19th century where there's all
these balance of power stuff where you can read the newspaper today and it's all
balanced with power,
with the shifting alliances.
I mean,
we,
you know,
Japan and Germany where our great enemies and now there are great allies and et
Cetera,
et cetera.
Russia and was an,
then it was an ally in world war one and two,
and then it looked like then they were an enemy and then they're in ally again.
Now maybe it'd be an enemy again.
It's,
it's,
it really doesn't read a terribly different,
differently.
So,
um,
so the purpose of all this kind of fighting for status is,
uh,
of course to gain access to females.
There's some degree of food and we'll talk about where their food is a real
scarce item for them or not.
It's usually not a scarce item,
but access to females,
I think I mentioned this last time,
is dependent on the status of males.
And so,
and it's not simply a size and aggressiveness at all that determines dominance.
But how good is social manipulator?
The individuals are,
uh,
and especially the females.
And if a male has not been nice to the female,
which means off sharing food with them,
uh,
they go and hunt colobus monkeys.
And if they catch a monkey,
uh,
how much of the meat it gets shared,
how much grooming they do,
and if the male is a use boorish,
uh,
the,
the other chimps who simply I shun him.
They just,
when he comes up and tries to start some kind of friendly and try and they just
turned their back on him and walk away,
he's shunned and isolated.
So the point is,
no matter how strong,
physically strong and violent as single male is,
he can never be Alpha without the support of the community.
It really is an not quite democratic,
but it has aspects of,
of a democratic choice that the male must have the consent of the community
before he can become dominant.
So this social acceptance,
the,
the value of your peers,
uh,
and your social status is really the deciding factor in who will be dominant and
therefore who will pass on his genes into the next,
uh,
generation.
Now going back to the females,
uh,
when the sex behavior of chimpanzees was first being observed,
the,
the observers were quite struck with the obvious promo promiscuity of the
females.
The females just didn't seem to care who made it them.
And we discussed that last time,
you know,
and in each mating cycle,
uh,
a female,
we made it by every single male in the troop and Jane Goodall's troop,
sometimes not quite so extremely.
And that was kind of a surprising,
given the theory that I've described to you,
that females should want something from the males.
They should want to choose either the male with the best genes or the male,
uh,
who's giving them the biggest gift or something.
And this just sort of compliance under any segment.
It was obvious that that's what they were observing,
but it didn't make any sense.
But finally,
uh,
they observe more of the chimps are obviously not terribly easy to observe and
over a lifetime.
So you know what's going on.
And the story is this,
that
when chimps are young,
either males or female,
the juveniles are under the domination of their mothers.
And the females,
the females meet with each other every so often.
So any female can dominate any young independent of sex.
And so you really,
if you just looked at the social behavior,
you wouldn't be able to distinguish a boy,
a boy,
infant girl,
infant.
And I'll give you some reading that human societies,
many what we call primitive human societies have the same thing that even the
words for a young boy at the same as for a girl,
that they're,
they're not distinguished only at some sort of puberty,
right to the boy.
Do the biological boys become socially constructed boys and in a sense,
but in chimpanzees.
So when,
when they're little,
um,
the females dominate them.
But of course the males start growing big and in adolescence they start to get
up to the same size of the female.
And then what happens is that these young males come and start attacking the
females for no obvious external reason.
And when this first happens,
the female is still bigger and she's swatting them away,
you know,
and,
and he runs off screaming.
Uh,
but as he gets bigger,
he comes back and seems to sort of choose one female at a time,
starting up on some mild dominance hierarchy among females.
Not very strong,
but a little bit there.
He goes to just gratuitously attacks one female after another and keeps doing
it,
pushes her punches,
her,
bites her,
pose the hair,
you know,
and she fights back.
But eventually he's big enough to cow her and he becomes dominant to that
female.
Then he goes to the next and the next and the next.
And eventually as they go through adolescence,
the young males become dominant to each female.
And then,
uh,
that's not the end of it.
That every so often thereafter they again,
gratuitously attack,
uh,
the females for no a particularly obvious reason.
Let me describe you one read to you one of the exam descriptions of these kind
of dominance attacks.
This is one of the people in,
uh,
studying in Jane Goodall's group and Gone Bay in Tanzania.
And this is,
uh,
she's recollecting.
Nearly 20 years ago,
I spent a morning dashing up and down the hills of Gone Bay trying to keep up
with an energetic,
a young female on her rear end.
She sported the small bright pink swelling characteristic of the early stages of
estrus.
She was just coming into her fertile period and really wasn't particularly
fertile at that time.
Um,
for some hours are run through the park was conducted in quiet quietly,
but then suddenly a chorus of male chimpanzee pantsuits shattered the
tranquility of the forest.
My female rushed forward to join the males.
She greeted each of them bowing and then turning to present her swelling,
a rear end for inspection.
You know,
hey guys,
get interested in me.
She's young and a little inexperienced.
She thought they would be real hot to trot,
but it didn't turn out.
And the male is examined her kind of perfunctorily and they saw she wasn't
really ready yet.
Uh,
and so they resumed grooming one another and showing no,
didn't,
no interest in this young female.
And they,
the scientists here,
the anthropologist was a rather surprised by listen difference to a potential
mate.
And then she understood,
she sorta recalled and there's that and well her swelling is really pretty small
so far,
so she's not ready.
So she realized it and we,
it would be a week or two before she was really going to be a fertile and uh,
then then there'll be really interested.
And so she was sort of watching this,
the,
the males basically grooming each other,
ignoring this,
this female,
and then boom,
all of a sudden they attacked,
the tech came without warning.
One of the males charge toward us.
The anthropologist was with the,
uh,
with the female,
one of the males charged Cortez Heron and looking twice as large as my small
female and enraged as he rushed by,
he picked her up,
her older to the ground and pummeled her.
She cringed and screamed.
He ran off,
rejoining the other males seconds later as if nothing had happened,
he taxed this one and then nothing happened.
And it was not so easy for the female to return to normal.
She whimpered and darted about Darden.
Nervous glances,
had her attacker,
and he was worried he was going to just charge it at her again.
And the,
the primatologists continues that in the years that follow cheese.
So many,
uh,
such assaults by this.
So what's the purpose of this?
Uh,
these,
these attacks do not end in sex,
so they're not rape.
Uh,
what happens is the male establishes the dominance over the female.
She's afraid of him,
as I told you.
They of course know each other individually and remember over many,
many years.
And so these,
these attacks during adolescence when they establish their dominance and then
the continual reminders that their garments and they can coerce them at any
minute,
uh,
is what the purpose of this is.
So when she does come into estrus and all the males are,
are around,
and there's only a very short window of opportunity when he may,
she may be alone,
the other males or fighting or not paying attention for a moment.
Remember,
he only needs 15 seconds.
When I described that last time for about,
of intercourse,
he has 15 seconds before the other males are going to come and interrupt him.
Uh,
so the last thing he wants is for her to resist.
She has to be compliant in that very short time.
Sort of like a private and an army.
Don't ask questions,
do whatever you're told immediately.
And this prior violence,
the purpose of this prior violence is to cow the females into submission at that
moment when they need this submission.
Um,
so,
uh,
so that,
that is,
uh,
the,
the chimp system.
It's to our eyes.
It's not a very pretty kind of system.
And you can think how much of that we still do something similar.
And that's up to you to decide.
So we've described now,
uh,
three other great apes aside from us.
And there's the fourth grade ape species,
which you probably have heard of,
uh,
or cold bonobos.
And for a long time they're very similar.
The chimps I showed you last time,
the evolutionary tree,
they've split off from chimpanzees.
Chimps and Bonobos have split off very recently.
So there's still very much the same.
The bonobos are a little bit smaller.
The difference in size between males and females is not so great,
but their behavior is enormously different.
Uh,
there's almost no violence,
uh,
in,
Nobo troop.
They,
the various Banabos troops,
uh,
don't get into a violent attacks with each other.
What they do is have sex a lot that anything that come,
anything that an a chimpanzee would probably illicit violent competition for
food come dish for females,
whatever they have sex.
And somehow that that diffuses it.
And um,
they do everything you can dream of.
Uh,
oh,
I didn't order or
what was going on here.
Somehow there's something wrong anyway.
Um,
what happens is,
uh,
males and males or females may initiate the sex about,
they often do it face to face,
which is not a usual animal sort of thing.
And the pictures that I had and I'd want to wear their why,
why they're not being pulled up.
His first a male and a female copulating sort of face to face and what you,
you'd recognize immediately what was going on.
And they seem happy about that.
And then I have no slide of two females going at it.
And what they do is they stand face to face and rub their genital regions
together.
And of course,
what are the primatologists that Jen and Phil Gentle rubbing,
perfectly neutral right now,
the locals where these,
these,
uh,
Benobos lived there much.
They understand better.
And so are the locals called Hoka.
Hoka.
So the long picture of hookah,
hookah and in the previous year,
I,
I hadn't,
I won't tell you the story.
Very interesting story,
uh,
afterwards.
Um,
so the question is,
uh,
and there's,
there's essentially no dominance of the males over the females are very little
dominance of the males over females.
You don't see this violent thing happening.
So you read about this demonic,
there's a several readings on Benobos cause I don't time in the lecture to talk
so much about them,
but,
uh,
it seems that what's going on is a Banabos live one side of the Congo River and
chimpanzees the other side and on the side where Bonobos are there also
gorillas.
And so they compete for the same food source.
Uh,
I'm sorry,
the chart side with the chimps are,
uh,
they're also,
I got this right.
Uh,
gorillas and so they compete,
uh,
for the food source.
There's not that much
food.
So the chimps have to forge pretty much alone.
The females get isolated and therefore they're subject to male dominance.
In the Bonobo territory,
there's more a greater food density so the females can stay together and forage
as a party.
And as you read it,
this female power,
the females stay together.
And if a male comes and tries to dominate one of the females,
her sister's support her and beat the mail off.
So in evolution,
and they've sort of given up trying that trick,
and now everybody copulates with everybody else.
And what do we call that when there's this great promiscuity?
What's the form of competition going on?
Sperm competition.
And so one of the ways that the Banabos evolve is that they're in evolution,
the testes get bigger and bigger.
And so you measure the ratio of tests to size in a Bonobo,
which has a lot of sperm competition to chimpanzees,
which have a lot,
a lot less,
very little because they fight,
the males fight each other.
And what you find is that as a fraction of total body size,
the dinobo testes are much larger than the chimpanzee testes.
Okay.
So,
uh,
we've seen four different models of male female relationships that rape and
orangutans,
infanticide in gorillas,
battering in chimps,
and total promiscuity in Bonobos.
Uh,
so one of the questions that you can ask is which one most resembles the human
condition?
Well,
it turns out that if you do the statistics in humans,
rape is relatively rare.
Of course,
we all know what happens,
but it's not a major event in fantasize,
which you'll see happens very frequently,
but not against the will of the mother.
The males,
uh,
not unrelated males.
Killing the infants of other females is a very,
very rare event in humans.
Again,
it happens,
but it's,
it's quite rare.
The common form of,
of Male,
female human violence,
what do we call it?
Battering,
right?
Battering is extremely common,
uh,
almost all over the earth and for as far back in history as we know.
So various studies have been done in different places in Punjab,
in north India,
uh,
75% of scheduled caste women that's lower,
lower caste women reported being beaten frequently by their husband's 75.
There's an agreement there.
75% of the men report beating their wives in Bangladesh.
47% of the women report having been beaten.
A study of 10 countries ranging from Japan to Ethiopia showed that in most sites
between 30 and 56% of the ever partner and this partner violence,
uh,
women had experienced both physical and sexual violence.
And of course these are almost certainly whenever you collect statistics on
something that is not exactly a appreciate it.
And this is hard a year,
you're getting a very low report.
These are certainly under reports cause people don't want to report it.
But also when you ask about,
you know,
not just casual,
a little bit of violence,
but you know,
is this severe,
have you been severely beating in a society where 75% of the women are beaten
frequently?
The standard for what they're going to call severe is going to be very high.
So if you've used our understanding of,
of male,
female battering,
the numbers would clearly be much,
much higher.
Uh,
and what's interesting is there's a fair amount of collusion between the males
and the females in,
in this,
uh,
beating this,
this battering,
uh,
both in the culture,
both the men and the women that feel that it is the husband's right to beat the
woman.
And it's,
and it's just right.
It's the woman's do.
She should be beaten.
And they talk about this quite openly,
uh,
40 to 80%.
And again,
in different surveys,
40,
80,
40 to 80% of wives agreed that a beating is justified if it will.
If a wife neglects household chores or is disobedient.
And again,
this will be,
it probably has a much more minor meaning.
Uh,
but this,
this be worth of beating would not be even considered disobedience by us.
Maybe probably very minor.
Severe beating is almost uniformly justified and can condone for many reasons,
including,
for example,
a husband,
a woman disobeying her husband's orders if it was been gives a woman a direct
order and she does not follow it.
She gets beaten.
Uh,
uh,
it's,
it's her duty to obey or husband and they describe it.
The women talking to each other and talking to investigate it,
describe it as selfish,
that when she follows what she wants to do and,
which of course there is always conflict between one person who wants to do and
person B,
then they said,
I was selfish,
I deserved a beating.
Or they say that if another woman,
she was selfish and she deserves a beating in the u s of course we have an
escape.
This,
this has now become,
uh,
it was hush hush for a very long time.
But now it's,
it's fairly open because of the feminist movement.
And the numbers are something like 50% of us women will be physically abused by
the men with whom they live.
So they're getting this as partner,
uh,
violence.
6 million will be really battered and that's way more,
you look at the say way more than rape and auto accidents and muggings and every
other kind of mishap put together.
So a battering seems to be,
uh,
both the chimpanzee mode of violence.
And it's not the Orangutang,
it's not the apron.
And certainly not,
uh,
not they rang,
not the grill.
And certainly not the Bonobo,
uh,
but humans seem to engage in the same kind of violence as,
as chimpanzees.
And the most wonderful quote that I have a describing,
uh,
this is from a Palestinian woman and she says,
men have small brains.
If you feed them,
cook for them and cleaned for them,
maybe then they will not beat.
You.
Think that's a great tag.
Okay.
Um,
so now I've spun a nice story for you,
right?
The way chimpanzees,
social organization around sex and reproduction.
And I don't know if any of you have noticed there's something really wrong with
the story.
Wrong,
incomplete,
incorrect.
Anybody think anything?
So what have I described to you?
I've scratched you in the first hand,
uh,
that these males fight with each other their whole lives.
So male,
he is not much else to do.
Feed and think about his,
his part in the dominance.
So in the whole year there's going to be one or two females ready to be
inseminated.
And what do they do the whole rest of the year?
They're fighting for dominance,
right?
And finally you get to have an Alpha male.
And most of the time he's in strong control and really can control,
uh,
all the other males.
Okay.
That's,
you know,
the naked ape kind of story,
which you've heard,
but whoa,
wait a minute.
What else have I also told you?
Every time the FEMA comes into estrus,
she does it with everybody,
right?
Those two stories don't jive with each other.
There's a,
there's some,
some contradictory thing going on there.
And that's the next part of the whole story that we have to figure out why since
the Alpha male could easily win,
when there's a really strong alpha male,
could easily keep all the other males away from the fear means only a couple of
weeks that she's at all fertile and he spent the whole year being boss.
You know,
why does he keep the other males away and get all the sexual activity for
himself?
It's an interesting,
it's,
it's a surprising thing and it tells you that something is missing from the
story.
Uh,
okay.
So this is where Jane Goodall comes in and she's responsible for almost
everything about chimpanzees and the whole field of primatology.
He's a real hero of mine,
uh,
angry that Yale has never given her an honorary degree,
even though she lives right here in Wilton in Connecticut.
It's really bad or shameful.
Okay.
So what's her story?
Just a little bit of personal interests.
Uh,
she was 23 years old in 1960 and he,
she,
she and her biography,
she always loved watching animals.
I mean,
she would go into the hen house and just sit there and her mother couldn't find
her and they,
you know,
look where the hands are.
Well,
that's where Jane Jane is.
She not,
not from a family that was sort of education bound.
She had not been to a university.
She had no particular career,
but she was invited to visit a friend in Africa and in,
and a lot of England,
a lot of time,
Africa,
sort of very romantic kind of place with every young person wants to go in and
see Africa.
So she took a job as a waitress because it wasn't trained to do anything else
and saved up enough money so she could get the steamboat passage,
uh,
to Kenya.
So she took a boat to Kenya in 1960
she bet up fairly soon with Louis Leakey and the,
and the expatriate community,
the English community there,
Louis Leakey,
you may have heard of his family,
has done all the paleontological,
the digging up of Lucy.
I think Lucy is one of theirs.
And all the other scouts I'm sort of rewritten,
uh,
the history of,
of human evolution.
And that the idea of basically being,
there were lots of branches that are species just didn't grow out of
chimpanzees,
but there were lots and lots of species floating around and most they,
all the others went extinct in what,
what survived as us.
And so here comes this young woman and she doesn't really have a job and she
needs some support and she loves African.
She loves animals.
And leaky gets an idea that,
well,
no one has been able to go out and see what chimpanzees do.
We know what they knew by that time,
they were our closest relative.
They didn't really understand about Benobos at that time.
And Banabos didn't live where he was anyway.
Uh,
and so he says to her,
you know,
how are you interested at all in,
in going out and trying to observe chimpanzees?
And uh,
she says,
yes,
yes.
And he says,
you know,
they,
they don't like human.
They run away,
you know,
and if they don't run away,
they'll probably try to attack you.
These are big violent beasties and uh,
you know,
you may be in physical danger and she says,
yeah,
I went to,
and then it says,
well,
you know,
you're an attractive young woman and you were,
what did I say,
23 or something?
And you know,
there aren't going to be any men around.
You're going to be living in the jungle basically by yourself.
I'm sure you want to do it.
Hi.
Yeah,
yeah,
I want to do it.
He says,
you know,
it's going to take you 10 years before you're going to be the same thing.
You have to get it,
get them accustomed to use that you can even observe them.
Then you have to be able to watch them over long periods of times to understand
their social behavior.
You really want to do it.
Yes,
she decides to do it.
And she later on recounts this discussion where he said it would take her 10
years and she said if I had done it for only 10 years,
I would not have seen,
uh,
the violence that I did eventually see.
In fact,
it took 25 years before she saw the events that I'm going to describe to you.
And so the,
the violent events that I'm going to describe orange chimpanzee communities
about once a generation,
more or less like humans,
if you take the time,
say in the West,
between the,
the Napoleonic wars and the 1870 war,
a little bit long from,
from the French Franco Prussian war,
the world war wound toward war two,
we seem to do it more or less every generation or so ballpark,
25 years.
And that's very variable.
And chimpanzee violence has that same sort of a,
of a character to it.
So in 62,
she started observing a group of night that it was a large group,
much larger than as usual.
There are 19 adult and adolescent males.
And then the long with females and the young and the main thing that they were
watching was the social behavior.
They weren't really interested in the physiology or that kind of stuff at the
time was really the social behavior.
So they watched who was doing what with whom.
And one of the one things they know who were two individuals that they consider
best friends,
Goliath and Joe Romeo and they spend very long time grooming each other and all
friendly interactions.
And they saw these two individuals interacting over six years and there's
nothing,
nothing but friendly.
So gradually this large group,
she,
uh,
had started banana feeding the group in order to be able to see them.
She would put out bananas and they would come in and get it and they would get
used to her that way.
And for a long time,
other scientists thought she may have distorted the behavior,
but it's,
it turns out everything she saw it has been a scene again when there was no,
no banana feeding.
So that that was not a real issue.
So she watched this group for for many years,
six years or so.
And then things started to change.
Gradually.
The true groups started separating those sort of a northern,
uh,
mountain hill with a ravine than a southern mountain and hill.
And,
uh,
one group started spending clung subset of this one big group.
So I was spending time on the Northern Hill and another group on the Southern
Hill.
And the northern group was somewhat larger but not a huge difference.
There are eight fully mature males in the northern group and only six in the
southern group along with three females,
for instance,
with the southern group.
And first he just,
they just watch how much time they spent.
They recorded everything and they started seeing the group split a little bit.
And then when,
but it wasn't absolute,
they were still seeing it in each other's territory.
But after awhile they never saw males alone in the wrong territory.
They started traveling only in groups when they were in,
uh,
the other,
territory.
And it was clear that they were beginning.
This one group was beating deficient into two rather separate groups.
One day,
uh,
six northern males,
most of the males were observed traveling together in their own northern
territory,
but they were near the border.
There was kind of patrolling what was becoming the border and they heard
calling,
uh,
from the south.
And so they became silent and then move very quickly,
uh,
directly to where they had heard the calling.
What they saw was goatee,
a southern male.
Uh,
he was feeding up in a tree and not doing anything particular.
He noticed them coming and he jumped down and ran away.
But Humphrey,
one of the,
the northern guys chased after him and tackled him.
And then Humphrey was big.
He,
once he had tackled him,
he got on top of them and held down his sat on his face actually,
and held his hands.
Another one came in,
held down the feet.
So they basically,
uh,
immobilized a goatee and then they started attacking him.
The other,
there's,
remember the six males to,
to hold them down.
Um,
they tacked,
he ripped off his skin gat and gashes on the face and the nose on the mound
puncture in the leg puncture wounds.
Uh,
in the ribs and eventually he was beaten so badly that he was just motionless
plot plopped out there in the attackers just left.
Then they didn't kill them or anything.
They just left,
but he was so badly wounded that he died shortly thereafter.
Anyway,
seven weeks later,
three northern males attack d and other southern male d runs up a tree and
starts trying to escape by jumping from,
from branch,
from,
from tree to tree.
But these are big animals and sometimes they grab it,
not strong enough.
Branch grabs a branch,
it cracks and he's left dangling.
So they pulled him down and the three man,
three males that had during the tech kept beating him and he first huddled up
and then he lay flat on the ground and no longer even trying to escape.
They were females in this party at this point when he was not so much a danger
anymore.
He was pretty emotional.
They joined in and the females then started dragging him.
He was faintly squeaking as they dragged them along the ground and in the
dragging the skin was torn from him.
And then they,
they start biting him and flying off his skin with,
with their teeth.
And then after he was sufficiently down,
they just left.
And he actually lived for,
for a few months.
His spine in his pelvis were protruding from outside the skin.
His scrotum has shrunk to one fifth of its normal size.
He died whole year,
passes five males attack Goliath.
Goliath is the one we talked about already,
who by this time,
it's an extremely old male with teeth worn down to the gum.
So clearly not a threat to anybody.
He was too old to,
to be a threat.
And Joe Romeo,
who had been his previous grooming partner,
you know what,
for six years they were,
they were buddies and he's part of the attacking party and he attacks,
uh,
Goliath,
just like any of the others.
Goliath was beaten for 20 minutes and he tries to protect his head,
but eventually he's too beaten and just gives up and lay still.
And in this particular case,
the adolescent males were along and they watch this,
they stay a safe distance away,
but they're watching this and they get,
you know,
very excited.
They,
they hoot and Holler and jumping all around.
You've probably seen kids,
human kids behave that way.
And then again,
once Goliath was pretty much immobilized,
they ran in and contributed their,
uh,
their degree of violence to this.
And again,
same story.
And they didn't bother to kill them.
They just went away.
But he died.
This continues,
uh,
and one after the other.
And three years after the first kill,
uh,
the northern males caught sniff who is the last remaining,
southern male.
And Satan was one of the attackers.
You've heard Satan before.
And he grabbed her by the neck and suck the blood from his nose.
He had,
and cutting the nosy suck the blood.
Two males grabbed one leg each and dragged him down into a ravine.
And again,
the same thing.
They beat him up.
They left him to die and he did indeed die.
So sniff was the last nail in the southern group.
The females were also not spared.
Madam B,
who's a crippled female and her daughter,
little B,
uh,
both were an estrous,
so both were sexually,
uh,
ready,
sexually available,
uh,
but didn't matter.
They were attacked and they had a series of attacks on,
on the females over the course of a year.
And in the last attack after she had stopped moving completely,
Jeremy,
me,
you know,
it was observed only the mail we've seen picked her up,
slams or are down stomps,
honor,
rolls are over and over along the slope.
And then he let her go.
But when she tried to get up,
another male comes in and slams into the ground again and beat her again till
she senseless.
And she dies five days after this attack.
So eventually the southern group was totally wiped out.
Uh,
they saw some killing of the juveniles of the infants,
uh,
but they couldn't observe that all.
And the presumption is that the infants that they didn't see actually being
killed,
they lost their mothers.
They consult,
they just died in the jungle somewhere.
But they never,
no,
no individual from the southern group was never seen again.
So what happens then?
So now,
uh,
this northern group,
the called the Casa Keela group,
uh,
is dominant.
They expand into the southern territory.
Now they have sort of basically twice the size territory and there's sort of
luxuriate in that in some sense.
And it lasts all of a year.
But then they come in contact with the next group to the south,
which is even stronger than they are.
And they had nine that,
that community had nine fully adult,
a fully mature males.
And so in the next year that's that next southern group starts attacking what
was the northern group and almost destroys them,
almost an NII lates.
Then they're pushed out of their newly one territory and even north of there
called prewar boundaries.
So there were soft and they want to be where before two wars.
And in the meantime they are being pushed north.
But there was another strong community in the north pushing south and it looked
very bad for this group and Jane Goodall and her and her staff by then and which
had grown fairly large,
was wearing,
you know,
they'd spend 20 years,
so 25 years studying these individuals had all their history known him.
It was the only group that they could really understand individuals or,
and it literally looked like they were just going to be wiped out.
As it turned out,
they got lucky that just at the time when it looked like her group was going to
be wiped out,
some of the adolescent males turn fully mature and the balance of power was
reestablished.
And when two groups or more or less equally strong,
they don't engage in fights.
These fights only happen when a group from one community goes and finds a single
individual from the other community and then they go and kill him or beat him up
very badly.
So the group that's attacking basically does not take any risks.
And in the course of these three years,
the northern group loss,
nobody and the southern group was totally wiped out.
They,
they only engage in this violence when they're sure to win.
And you,
you can read about human primitive warfare as it has very much the similar,
uh,
character.
So as soon as this group got,
got strong enough,
by the luck of adolescent males,
uh,
becoming a fully adult,
what they then the two groups would meet at a,
at the boundary,
and they'd scream and yell at each other and bang their chests and all this kind
of stuff.
And,
uh,
but then they back off and retreat into their,
their territory.
So,
uh,
good all's group was,
was saved.
Now the question comes up as I mentioned,
uh,
does this have anything to do with the banana feeding?
Did Somehow Jane Goodall's treatment of these,
uh,
these animal groups,
they saw a big group in the beginning.
Maybe that wasn't a natural group.
Maybe it was two different groups that came into that sort of joined for the
purpose of getting bananas.
Uh,
and then they reverted to their prior hostility,
separateness and hostility.
Uh,
there was no way to really know that a new,
a whole lot of other hypotheses why this couldn't be the case that everybody
knew.
Jen Good.
I had herself before she sold this word published of lovely book saying how
peaceful chimps were.
And there was all this popular literature about how,
you know,
humans were rogue species.
We're the only ones that kill each other.
We're the only ones that go to war.
You were really bad.
And it's modern civilization or capitalism or imperialism or you know,
all of these cultural things that,
why,
what has made humans such as such a bad species,
cause chimps are nearest relatives were just so wonderful.
Uh,
and so there are,
people are thinking of all kinds of reasons why what they saw was not true.
Uh,
but meanwhile,
the Japanese who were very,
very strong in this field,
and again,
females are really almost dominant in this field.
I know that they have the patients to go there and watch for such a long time.
But,
uh,
this,
the,
even in both in America and Japan and England,
uh,
the female researchers are some of the very best.
So,
uh,
they again,
they observed a group of Japanese were in a different part of Africa,
uh,
for 10 years.
Nothing but peace.
Then during the second decade,
so years 10 to 20,
uh,
all six adult males of the smaller community,
they also had several minutes containing 22 members managed one by one,
apparently due to the aggression by males of the other too much larger
neighboring communities who are dominant because of their size,
size in this case,
meaning number of adult
males.
Now in this case,
they didn't kill the females,
but one after another,
the females of the annihilated community transferred with they're surprising
offspring,
uh,
to the victorious m group.
And the m group also got control of the k group's territory.
Now the exception to this transfer of the females who were the young is that the
adolescent males were not allowed to,
did not transfer,
and probably we're not allowed to transfer.
And they just basically stayed in the old territory and wasted away and died
without their social community.
All the males were dead in,
the females had transferred.
So the troop,
and they apparently weren't allowed in.
So now is this just sort of random violence,
man,
it takes three years and they're,
you know,
a fair number of attacks.
But it wasn't like every week they had another,
another battle.
So it was sporadic.
Is this just sort of casual violence or,
or,
or was there some kind of uh,
in this,
and uh,
let me cut to the chase here.
So
usually a chimpanzee is,
there are many examples of this,
but we only have time for like one.
Um,
usually the chimpanzees,
when they sleep at night,
the males will get together and not write one tree in the next,
they make nests up in the trees,
but within a reasonable,
it doesn't,
so they can call to each and they call to each other before they go to sleep to
know where of,
where have you built a nest,
where are,
where are we all?
And the usually fairly noisy about that.
But one night I'm Marico Hasegawa,
a Japanese woman scientist,
uh,
was observing them and she noticed and quite startling me.
There was no,
no,
no pan Tootie.
They weren't telling me they weren't making any,
any noise.
And she had never experienced that before.
And she was,
she was surprised.
The next morning the troop got up and started attacking a neighboring troop.
They singled out a mother and her infant and attacked and killed them.
And so why would they sign up the previous night,
which he had never seen before?
It looks like not only each individual was planning,
but it was a group thing.
No one in the group,
uh,
w was making any noise.
So this had somehow been decided as a group effort,
uh,
the night before,
when they're going to attack several males together,
we'll leave the core of their range and travel [inaudible] purposely towards the
periphery rather than just wandering around.
And I'll tell you a little bit about the wandering.
Um,
and there,
it's really has all the aspects of planned ahead and purpose of,
and this is really something that they plan to do.
The purpose of this violence has not at all clear.
There's contending schools,
uh,
about this.
The most obvious one is they get more territory and there they therefore they
get more trees,
more food.
Uh,
they live largely on fruit and largely on figs.
There's a lot of fig trees and all jungles and uh,
and so they just wander around and find a fruit tree.
And then depending on how much truth there is,
they either go up and eat themselves or they can call over someone else and say,
Hey,
I found a good fruit tree.
Most of the time the chimps have no problem finding food.
Uh,
Jane Goodall,
uh,
had one of her workers follow an adult male for 50 days.
Never.
I out of sight.
And one of the things they notice,
did he ever go looking for food in this 50 days?
Never did he try to hunt food?
We just hold,
wander through through the jungle and every solvent,
his foot would step on a rotting fruit and squish and he would notice how he'd
look up and there's,
there's a tree full of fruit and climb up and eat.
And maybe call over,
uh,
some others.
So she was definitely of have the impression that,
uh,
that food is not a limiting factor for them.
Uh,
later and Pusey and another scientist,
uh,
came the opposite conclusion that there she noticed there's some sort of
dominance Harvard among females.
Those females would have more fruity trees and where they range do better.
Reproductively and Richard Wrangham who you'll read some of his stuff,
he's a food man.
So there's a whole group and not wildly convinced by the evidence,
but you know,
I'm not in the field.
There's a big thought that food limitation is,
is important.
So for instance,
the different stream bonobos and chimps has been ascribed to food density and
the size of the parties and,
and,
and so forth.
One of the problems with the food idea is that,
uh,
they have fairly large chair Tories and the young healthy adults can basically
always find food.
They'd never seem to starve to death.
It's the older individuals who are quite sick and not so mo tile,
uh,
that seemed to have trouble finding food and they can get trouble in,
in the dry season.
When there's a lot less fruit but they're probably too weak to,
even when they have territory a,
they're too weak to even,
you know,
they just can barely searched territory a and if you give them twice as big a
territory,
may not do them any good because they just don't have the energy to go search
it.
So,
uh,
I think the,
the,
the field is moving toward the idea that that food is the important thing.
The evidence that I've seen doesn't convince me yet,
but again,
I'm not an expert in this whatsoever.
So the other,
of course,
the other purpose of course to acquire females.
I've been going on and on about how rare an egg is.
And so you think,
well that's the obvious reason,
but then you watch them go and they kill the females,
even the female's in estrus.
So that doesn't make a lot of sense.
Although the Japanese group,
sometimes the females do transfer.
And the story there is,
is quite interesting because as you know,
a small groups of individuals,
if they interbreed,
if the group was sealed,
if you know the males are sealed,
they stay together in this one community,
like forever for generation of generation.
But if the females also stayed there,
it would be an in inbreeding group and inbreeding gives big genetic problems.
So all species have to have some mechanism of gene flow and have to get jeans in
from the outside or sent and or send their jeans out.
So it turns out that in chimpanzees,
the females have access to other troops and they go out and have intercourse
when they're away and exactly how this is done because the males watched them.
When they come into estrus,
they must disappear before coming into estrus and have it out there.
It's not really known but,
but now they can do the genetics.
And again,
something like half of the babies are born with fathers that are not from the
troupe where they're resident in.
Very often the adolescent females who just transferred troops altogether.
And it's very interesting when a female tries to transfer,
go into another group,
if she's never had a young,
she's almost always accepted if she's had a,
if she's not,
if she's already really in this group because she's had a young,
very often attacked or even killed or,
or,
or kicked out,
kicked out.
So there's something,
for some reason that's not understood at all,
a virgin female basically is much more acceptable for transfer then,
uh,
an older female and that's not really understood.
Um,
so that means since the females are going to move around anyway and biologically
the,
the social things,
it has to be that way.
It doesn't make a lot of sense that they're,
that they're doing this for fee for,
to get extra females.
So,
uh,
there's a lot of,
a lot of unknowns here.
All right,
let me summarize this by the,
the summary of the,
of the chimpanzee social system.
So the PRI could come back to the question,
why do the males,
why is the Alpha male not dominate a totally the sexuality?
So,
and the reason is that these groups fighting each other a lot of,
we don't really know the reason why they finished,
but they fight each other.
And the winner is always the group.
So far,
always the group that has the most adult males and the group that is the
attacking group basically takes no casualties whatsoever.
So having a lot of adult males is very important.
If an Alpha male got so aggressive that he kicked out all the other males,
he wouldn't last long.
The other communities would come in and annihilate him.
So because of this fighting between the communities,
the males have to stay together in,
once the males have to stay together,
uh,
that means they're going to compete for females.
If the competition was such that only the alpha reproduced than evolution would
push all the other males into some other strategy.
As we've seen the big and the small,
uh,
um,
orangutans.
And you're going to read about our whole variety of sexual strategies.
You think that is heterosexual,
homosexual?
No.
There's lots of different,
lots of different versions,
which you will read about.
So evolution would push the other males to fight all the time to get to them.
If,
if they were not reproducing,
they would then be pushed by evolution to either fight all the time with the
Alpha male or go away and try to start their own troop or do something that it's
not a stable situation.
Only one individual can reproduce and everyone else can't.
So the males have to compete with each other.
All the males have to have some chance of being of fathering children.
This also has many subsidiary advantages.
So every male thinks he could be the father of any of the young and the troops
and they're all very protective.
Once it was seen that,
uh,
mother was coming back into estrus and becoming sexually interested,
the Alpha male was whether it was about to start copulating with her,
her young who did not want to be evolution.
No,
it doesn't want a brother because she wants all the resources and attention of
the mother.
He gets in between them.
And so it's finding,
and in fact,
he bites the scrotum of the Alpha male.
There's little,
little Tyke,
you know,
really clearly a sub,
even not even adolescent yet.
And so what is the Alpha male do?
He stops what's bends down,
very gently,
picks him up,
takes him over here,
plop some down,
and goes back to the mother.
Because even though when that infant was born,
that Alpha male was not the alpha.
So it's probably someone else might've,
might've been his.
So this uncertainty of paternity is what the May all the males protect all of
the young.
So because there's males,
the males fight for this dominance.
The males get bigger,
uh,
than the females,
and then they can coerce the females.
And so I think,
and that's why you see all this mail on not only male on male violence,
but male and female violence.
So I think the story does in the end fit back together.
But the driving force seems to be the fight between the different groups of
males,
which require males.
They've got evolve,
a social situation in which a lot of males competing with each other can hang
together.
Okay.
Um,
so it's,
it's an,
it's an interesting thing that it's because the battles between the males are
not decisive.
The Alpha doesn't kill the other because it's balancing.
The males are not decisive that the males then turn on the females to do
violence with them.
Okay.
Next time we will start on humans and we will describe humans and you will make
up your minds.
And how much of this is relevant to humans are not so see you on Tuesday.